[Musique]
on entend souvent dire peut-être
réaliste pas d'image quotidienne pour
des millions de personnes ont la tribune
il en est la caricature c'est nous 2011
aujourd'hui qui cherchent un emploi
alors qu'on propose à nos parents de
travailler de quatre pièces et qu'on
n'est même pas capable d'en garantir un
revenu décent
parce que c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
croire c'est que ce serait d'abord un
problème démographique alors qu'on sait
tous que c'est d'abord un problème de
proportions entre ceux qui travaillent
et ceux qui travaillent
on ne dira jamais assez mais y aurait
pas deux millions et demi de shauna
aujourd'hui ne se posera même tout
simplement parce que devrait dominer
toutes les propositions des pensions
capitalisation c'est l'insécurité la
plus totale
c'est le contraire de la solidarité
parce que d'abord c'est chacun pour soi
et puis c'est jouer au casino son propre
avenir parce qu'il va confier l'argent
des cotisations sociales de millions de
personnes à quelques assureurs à
quelques quartiers qu'un seul pianiste
est celui de réaliser de penne retraite
en somme c'est les retraites
participation
ils ont aussi les succès bientôt la
poste traite les gens avec un facteur
aujourd'hui c'est ma marque choix de
civilisation
même la nature doit être racheté par la
poignée d'années les bailleurs nous on
pense que la protection de
l'environnement
c'est contradictoire avec les pirates au
problème c'est de savoir à qui on fait
confiance aux multinationales soient
population parce qu'elles sont loin d
vraiment leur a dit aux populations de
chamonix le tunnel du mont blanc sera
sûrement pas la pierre aux camions sont
mandel radio population de tours
le pôle chimique je serai toujours faire
bientôt l'école de l'être humain avec la
nature
c'est annie des courbes au contre-sommet
des océans polaires qu'on empêche d'être
détruits de l'air qu'on empêche d'être
inconnu
des rivages on empêche d'être décalé et
il faut bien dire parce que ça fait pas
l'économie des guerres tout aucune
raison d'être et qu'il faut aller
je crois que ça reparte enfants
prenaient tout parce que des paysans
sans terre de porto allègre aux
centaines de milliers de jeunes qui
étaient à gènes cet été contre le sida
ont traité dans les rues de barcelone
notamment contre le sommet européen les
bailleurs de la volonté qu'un autre
quand on voit qu'il ya quelques
multinationales pharmaceutiques
qu'impose un monopole carrément à raison
sur l'accès à des soins pour des
maladies telles que le sida
why aujourd'hui nouvelle génération qui
veut que les multinationales arrête de
faire la loi
un autre monde est possible la prise de
conscience à dieu on peut changer
l'ordre des choses et si vous passez
d'un réel car comme disait baudelaire
pour ma part je quitterais sans regret
un monde dans lequel l'action ne serait
pas assurée
[Musique]